this is Jocko podcast number 380 with
Echo Charles and me Draco willink good
evening Echo good evening
so recently on the Underground podcast
we cut I covered one
quote from the e ching
which is a ancient script iching from
China and e means change
it actually looks like it says I
that means change
and Ching means script so this book is
commonly called
the book of changes original author
unknown it got modified over the years
uh Confucius I think is the most famous
person that kind of added to it
another some other guy another
character slash myth slash Legend uh
fushi and again I'm not any kind of an
expert on this stuff I just wanted to
kind of touch it from the surface here
but he created
the yin yang symbol so the yin yang is
our symbol that everybody knows from
well at least from Town and Country
surfboards TNC
um but also it's just a common symbol
you see it's in every cheesy martial
arts movie right you hear a little Yin
Yang in there it's in kind of new age
spirituality you'll get that yin and
yang going we've seen a lot of yin and
yang tattoos right here from especially
from back in the day I'm gonna say
80s 90s you know let's throw some yin
yang tattoos have to still be happening
but they were pretty popular back then
so we got that common symbol of Yin and
Yang and the story behind that is before
the universe before there's anything
there was just Stillness and there was
emptiness and then these two energies
these two
cheese
collided made the universe that's yin
and yang so in this book iching it's
made up of these little characters not
language characters but stacks of lines
literally stacks of lines a broken line
is Yin yin and a solid line is Yang
and these two when you stack these lines
you can stack them in ways that
represent the eight fundamental natural
parts of
of
Earth really fire so it's it's fire
water wind
Thunder one of them says River but I
think it's like River Lake maybe even
ocean in there Mountain Earth and Heaven
if you put these three things together
um there's a there's a way of writing
this out just you're basically drawing
lines stacking lines
and and here's what I'm getting with
this they made this thing for
divination which is the predicting of
the future so
divination is something that we do in
America believe it or not you ever drive
down the road and you see like Palm
Reader that's a that's divination that's
I'm gonna predict the future or
astrology you read in the newspaper
that's divination like oh I was born in
October so when the seventh moon is in
the dark side that means that I should
move on my new you know theories or
whatever yeah sure uh crystal ball yeah
like there's people that read crystal
balls that's called scrying you can read
mirrors you can read crystal balls
numerology you ever heard about these
people that would base their I think
Nancy Reagan was in a numerology where
it's like well you know what this today
is the 13th of this you know seventh
month and therefore that equals 20 and
20 is my lucky number so you know what I
mean that kind of thing so all these
things are
are called divination
and that's sort of what the E Ching has
become in a way or it became and you end
up with this thing where they they call
these things
um
hexagrams where basically it looks like
six stacked lines and it's all these
different arrangements and so you you
have these so it's a solid line and a
broken line all right so you have like a
solid line or a broken line those are
the two types of lines you can have it's
binary you can have one or the other and
they stack these lines in different ways
and it means different things so the top
three lines might mean water and the
bottom three lines might mean Earth and
there you from that combination
You can predict different things right
that's that's what it is so like for
instance hexagram five
which is waiting but it's not just
waiting it's inner certainty it leads to
perseverance that brings good luck so
that that's what it is that's that's how
this works
and what they what you end up with is
really like a bunch of sayings
and
um
you can do it with throwing coins again
to predict these things I don't want to
go too deep in this because frankly I'm
not a Believer okay I'm not a believer
in palm reading I'm not a believer in
astrology I'm not a believer in this
kind of stuff yeah I'm not a believer in
throwing they do with pennies or with
whatever coins and like a head is one
and a tale of something else and you can
that's how you can predict so if you
Ponder your question and then you throw
the coins and then it tells you what
kind of line to draw and it's going to
work it out for you okay so again I'm
not into this kind of thing yeah but
here here's the thing
there is some basic philosophical
guidance in the iching that completely
makes sense that's why we covered look I
was I something I had some copy of it
and when we did we did one quote on the
Underground podcast and I was like you
know what
there's a lot there is a lot of I almost
want to use the word wisdom but I also
just want to use the word common sense
and sometimes common sense and wisdom
are very similar they're very close to
each other you know when something seems
like Common Sense yeah that's prop that
person that's executing some real Common
Sense moves probably has a decent amount
of wisdom oh yeah and some of these
things in the iching
represent some pretty good wisdom and at
the same breath you could also say well
that's common sense yeah hey
I get it right
you can and you know this also
boils down to like the old oracles yeah
you know in ancient times there would be
oracles that would make prediction like
the famous one is you know the big
leader comes and says should we go to
war with the Enemy and the Oracle says
if you go to war
powerful Nation will fall
yeah and so a person's like oh cool
we're gonna win yeah but
it actually doesn't predict anything
right also to you you mentioned the
common sense thing where
that is real I think I believe what is
that the ancient wisdom is almost like
it's rooted in common sense yes so like
you know like the old school uh
what was it I don't know who said I
forget but it's they said um
do not kill mosquito with bazooka or
something yep there you go it's like
that kind of ancient wisdom and Common
Sense yeah but at the same time so it
seems like common sense
no that was on um what was that movie
with Sean Connery anyway oh entrapment
anyway he said uh so yeah uh do not kill
mosquito with bazooka right or whatever
but at the same time what that means
probably applies to a bunch of things
that man if you just stop and think it's
like okay you know he can probably help
you out in a lot of situations like
ancient quote-unquote philosophy that
applies sure said simply which is kind
of part of the wisdom yes can apply to a
bunch of things if you just stop and
think so everything that you're saying
right now is when I is why when I read
through the eating I was like you know
what this is worth covering because
there's some quote ancient wisdom
or quote common sense
that if you utilize it's going to help
you and look
um
could I be in the zone could could I
could you take my what I kind of things
that I say and turn it into a powerful
divination that would help you like we
could create some kind of a like a magic
eight ball sure remember that magic
eight ball hell yeah Magic 8 Ball same
thing right magic eight balls divination
we should have brought that up as a form
of divination because you shake the
magic eight ball and it says the outcome
is certain right and it just gives you
these things that have no meaning but
but what's interesting about them is
let's say you were like oh should I you
know ask that girl on a date and you
shaking it says the outcome is certain
yeah hell yeah yeah yes it's gonna work
well the outcome also might be certain
that she rejects you but you don't
really know that you have a good
attitude so you go ask her out she says
yes maybe she says no yeah but you know
we could make like an a magic eight ball
with uh you know ancient Jocko wisdom in
it right and you shake the eight ball
and it says work hard yeah that's a good
answer like well hey I'm really having a
problem with my with my job right now
what should I do work hard oh I'm really
having a problem with my relationship
right now what should I do work hard I'm
really having a problem staying in shape
right now what should I do work hard uh
be disciplined right oh well you know I
I just seems like I'm really having a
hard time getting getting forward at my
job be disciplined like it's gonna be a
good answer yeah eat clean hey I'm
having a hard time getting focused eat
clean I'm having a hard time falling
asleep eat clean like you see what I'm
saying like these are just do Jiu Jitsu
what's sad what's funny about you it's
not sad
like on the Underground podcast where
people have things going on in their
life at least 50 of the time I have to
throw in there dude you just because
it's actually accurate yeah it's gonna
make things better if you're doing Jiu
Jitsu yeah so eat clean
you know work hard be disciplined do Jiu
Jitsu those kind of things you could put
on a magic Jocko eight ball and they
would make sense and they would actually
help you
they would actually help you do not make
excuses do not make excuses boom that's
another one you know so those things I
mean what would you say was the opposite
would you say like hey be you be lazy is
that advice you're gonna give someone no
are you going to eat junk you're gonna
tell that someone no it doesn't make any
sense so there's a a certain amount of
common sense to these things just like
there's a bunch of common sense to stuff
that I say just like there's a bunch of
common sense to things that
when people get traction about how to
live better normally it's like when you
look at it it's there's definitely some
common sense advice in there and again
everything that we're talking about is
why as I read through the iching I
thought you know what this is there's
there's definitely some
ancient wisdom or common sense depending
on how you want to look at it and you
don't have to get spiritual you don't
have to
um believe in the Divination and draw
the yarrow sticks there's a bunch of
different ways you can do it yeah
there's a bunch of different ways that
you can use this stuff but I think if
you just read what they say you're gonna
end up in a pretty good spot so let's
get into this this is the iching um and
and so each one of these things and I'm
not going to waste a bunch of time oh no
no sorry I'm not gonna waste time I'm
not gonna go over what the little
hexagram looks like but in your mind
just picture that every one of these
things could be
either six solid lines or is six lines
either solid or broken lines that's what
you get all right so hexagram one
Heaven above heaven below so it says the
universe is united in power so too the
wise person executes his actions with
power and creativity
exceptional progress comes by correct
persistence
is that Earth shattering it certainly is
not but this is what I think is so
interesting about this let's say you
were concerned about
you know where you're at with your
health Fitness family whatever like take
take a pic of what issue you're running
into in your life and it says hey
execute your actions with power and
creativity
and exceptional progress is going to
come from persistence okay that's good
advice you're gonna get better yeah
next one the receptive Earth is in power
the wise person follows the natural path
of calmness and correct persistence
others may lead while you support their
goals this is like as soon as I got to
that one I was thinking to myself
there's look
others may lead while you support your
goals I tell this to people all the time
at Echelon I tell those people at least
twice a week I'm telling let them take
lead hey if someone's got if someone's
got a good plan cool go go help them
Provide support
we have it in dichotomy leadership
sometimes you lead sometimes you follow
that's good that's exactly what they're
saying others may lead while you support
their goals that's a good thing
there's no there's no there's rocket
science there for sure
hey and I'm I'm skipping the part where
it says hexagram three water above
Thunder below
and the overall word is confusion so I'm
skipping that kind of part just to get
to the meat of these statements at least
most of the time
undertake no distant goal but organize
support
concern yourself with problems of the
moment now what's interesting about this
one is this is a little bit of
prioritized and execute right there's a
little bit of prioritize next to you
which is hey there's problems that are
right now right in front of your face
you gotta you gotta get those problems
solved
I don't like the idea of undertake no
distant goal but this is a common theme
throughout this throughout the iching
which is more focused on what's right in
front of you I think there's a little
bit of the
sort of the Eastern philosophy of like
living in the present living in the
moment I think there's a lot of that in
here which I think actually the opposite
of make sure you're thinking strategic
make sure you're thinking long term
hmm
that one it strikes me as the old um you
know thing you hear a lot like don't
don't worry or focus on the outcome
focus on the on the procedure you know
yeah yeah yeah destination yeah it's not
the journey or the focus on the journey
not the destination yeah that's you're
right so there you go that's that's an
interpretation that everybody says right
now right you gotta wait what do they
say you gotta love the process love the
process yeah everybody wants that
Mercedes right now but you gotta love
the process right right that's a thing
yeah and that's you're right that is a a
better take than what I said
undertake no distant goal but organize
support oh you know what that means
don't worry about that long term don't
worry about that Mercedes right now yeah
worry about the process
yes it feels like the use of the word
goal is just like
slightly slightly different than maybe
one might feel the use of the word goal
is like now today with us you know it's
like when you say hey let's set some
really good goals you know set some
goals that's like
things you want to aim for more so than
a very specific outcome you know it's
it's it's not totally different but it's
slightly different it feels like and
plus you know sometimes work different
languages have totally different words
that mean like it's close yeah yeah it's
true uh Carlos is who Mendes yeah he's
redoing the Spanish version of extreme
ownership yeah to make it highly
accurate because Carlos obviously was in
the SEAL Teams he's a fluent Spanish
speaker he's instructor Echelon front he
teaches now the material in Spanish to
our Spanish-speaking clients and
he you know he's pointed out to me he
says hey here's what this means in
Spanish it technically does mean what
you say in English but it technically
means it but it actually means a little
bit different and here's the better word
yeah yeah that's so true so if you put
it through chat GPT and just said
translate this it would just translate
spit out whatever the English word and
translate it to that direct closest
matching Spanish word that it knows out
of context right yeah so that's what we
got going on right now we're actually
going to republish the Spanish version
of that and and we're gonna do a Spanish
speaking where Carlos is going to do the
the audiobook in Spanish it's awesome to
have you know a fluent speaker of
Spanish to be able to go that deep yeah
yeah and that's a that's a important
distinction because how you said you
said GPT or Google translate or whatever
when you're like oh I heard this word in
this sentence in this other language hey
what does that word mean there you you
you Google translate it or whatever
and it spits out this word and you're
like wait a second then why would they
use that word it doesn't make sense but
you translate the whole expression
they're like okay that's like an ex a
whole expression that happened to use
that word just like because of the very
reason that you just said where it's the
word what do they call uh it's like
literal translation right they call it
but then the expression has a
translation kind of almost in a way
separate from a little translation when
that book comes out we'll we'll have
Carlos on and we'll talk through the
different words that and why this is the
best word bro that helps so much because
you know like I always tell you like in
Hawaiian this is just pigeon this is
technically English but it's pigeon
there's different Expressions that just
like how you said man it's like it's
similar but it's different like when
you're expressing a whole expression
like you're gonna be saying different
things and they say like like the idea
of slippers right in Hawaii slippers is
flip-flops that's what slippers are in
Hawaii when in Hawaii when you say
slippers you mean flip-flops right in
the main what do you what do you say
when you want to refer to you slippers
like what do you say when you want to
refer to something you're wearing around
their house that are like first slippers
house slippers yeah but here's the thing
though and this is this is probably I
don't know exactly why but I'm sure this
it has something to do with this idea
people don't wear how slippers in Hawaii
yeah go barefoot they take off their
shoes in Hawaii so there's a house
slippers really rare you're gonna see in
Hawaii generally speaking so there's no
real expression unless you're okay how
slippers then how slippers is different
than that all right but even I would
think I don't know I could be wrong but
given my experience you know why if you
said house slippers if I didn't have any
experience like with the mainland like
house slippers
and you just lived in Hawaii you'd be
like what you have an extra pair of
slippers that you wear in the house
which makes no sense because why would
you keep shoes on in the house it
doesn't make sense you know no one
really does that is it or are we taking
off the shoes like in every time you go
to a house yeah that's yeah that's
customary that is how yeah for sure and
then also the idea of uh no shame right
I tell you that one all the time no
shame in Hawaii no shame means don't be
shy
but in the mainland it's like it's more
of a negative thing like he had no shame
like he should be ashamed of himself but
he had no shame you know kind of a thing
it's kind of that's different so un in
certain contexts if you're trying to
convey whatever message it is in your in
Hawaii and you say oh yeah no shame
it'll be more like hey he wasn't being
shot you know but in the mainland he was
like oh he had no shame he'd be like oh
that guy should have been ashamed of
himself and he wasn't you know kind of a
thing so it's weird but yeah so you need
that kind of stuff yeah so some of these
words like goal yeah who knows what
direct translation really would be and
then look I might be translating it
to English and you might be translating
it to English and even if both of us
were fluent in Chinese and fluent in
English we still might
you know my vibe might be a little bit
different than yours you know so I might
pick the word discipline and you might
pick the word cruising no I don't know
all right next one
as water collects at the base of the
quiet Mountain the enlightened person
finds his level
through learning
decisiveness and correct persistence
so this is basically telling you to get
better the idea of correct persistence
by the way is also all it's in here a
lot correct persistence and what's
what's interesting about that is
that's
throwing a a caveat on persistence
because it's not like hey you just keep
going no matter what that would be just
persistence hey I'm just gonna be
persistent but a certain point correct
persistence is you know what maybe
that's not quite the right thing to keep
going after right now like you didn't
get it done
you can't get it done you're wasting a
bunch of time resources and expenses so
you want to use correct persistence not
just persist but correct persons so
that's in here a lot but to think that
you're going to find your level in life
by learning
that's
smart wisdom we should listen next one
do not be anxious but wait with
confidence
the moment will arrive when correct
persistence brings progress
again if you were shaking your eight
ball like I don't know if I should keep
going of college
what does it tell you hey correct
persistence is going to bring progress
be patient
don't be anxious okay or you're working
on a project and it feels like it's
overwhelming you shake your magic eight
ball or you throw your your coins and it
tells you hey the moment will arrive
when correct persistence break okay
great I'm gonna keep going so this is
just common it's a nice way of telling
you hey freaking keep working bro yeah
that's what it's saying yeah
uh next one heaven and water strength
and profundity conflict avoid
confrontation yield with caution persist
not against obstacles and this is so
good it's so good like avoid
confrontation that's smart
that's smart now sometimes people paint
that in a negative way like oh that
person avoids conflict right
person is going to avoid confrontations
but if you're doing something that I
don't like and I choose to build a
relationship with you and use an
indirect method and gain your trust and
confidence and you start to listen to me
and I start to listen to you and then I
can get you to stop doing something that
doesn't make that I don't like great
that's good yeah and that's what they're
talking about here yeah you guys uh you
Carlos Mendez is uh one of the
proliferators of this expression came
from you is nothing good has ever come
from an antagonistic relationship so
it's essentially that right where the
idea of like conflict like avoid
conflict in a good way like no one's
saying
fear conflict no one's saying that
because that's the way we all feel like
oh he just likes to avoid conflict you
know like out of fear what it should be
is avoid conflict because there's a
better way to resolve the situation
that's going to be more efficient faster
and it's going to end up with a better
result yeah that's what it should be
sure yeah you know what I mean because
people here oh avoid confrontation okay
joggers is a pushover it's like no I'm
actually going to win in the long run in
a more effective way we're going to have
a better relationship and things will
work out better overall in the end
that's what I'm doing now you can go and
confront people all day long and build a
bunch of bad relationships and have
antagonistic feelings with the people
that you work with you can do that yeah
and you might think you're being
directed is really helpful but it's not
and it's interesting too that the next
thing it says avoid confrontation but
then there's a dichotomy to that because
the next thing it says is yield with
caution so I'm not just like oh you know
Echo wants to do it this way oh I gotta
go okay is that the smartest thing to do
so there's a nice little balance between
avoiding confrontation and yet still
paying attention to when you yield
and then persist not against obstacles
now clearly well not clearly but my
assumption is that means sort of like an
impassable obstacle what are you going
to do keep beating your head against the
wall no don't persist against an
obstacle that's there instead find
another way around it don't waste a
bunch of energy ancient wisdom coming at
you don't beat your head against the
wall next one the wise person will find
strength in the company of many fellows
oh be a part of a big group
build a team
with leadership there will be correct
persistence and good fortune yep work
together as a team have good leader
you're gonna go you're gonna
everything's gonna go good yeah
do you so I'll think about the idea of
leadership on the way down here by the
way what was I don't know but
it's crazy because I'm literally
thinking about leadership almost 24
hours a day but you know okay so part of
the reason why why it's so valuable to
you is because you've come to pretty
much as far as I understand pretty much
100 of understanding what leadership is
and the value of it so a lot of people
they don't a lot of A lot of people
they think how you guess what that
traditional leader and I want to be the
if someone wants to be the leader or is
interested in leadership for themselves
they think oh I want to be the boss I
want to be the guy in charge I want to
be the you know so it's almost like
maybe like a little maybe an ego or an
narcissistic or a like power hungry or
whatever kind of a thing an idea don't
make me start talking about the
psychology of military and confidence
right now authoritarian mindsets don't
make you do that well okay we can't do
it we've done it for four podcasts but
okay keep in mind even if you think of
the idea of the benevolent leader you
still have a lot of some flavors of oh
you want to be in charge you want to be
the hero you want to be like that's the
that's how it lands I think generally
speaking but leadership is not so right
hey if I showed up to the new team and
it's like hey guys guys don't worry I'm
a benevolent benevolent leader it's the
same type of arrogance that comes across
right at least some hints of some smells
of that for sure but here's what
leadership actually really is more
comparable to so let's say you're you're
playing Legos okay so well actually
um okay my parents no no I'm just gonna
say this no big deal of course Legos
were like the high-end thing my freaking
parents got me something called lock
blocks so here's the deal and they might
still be around I don't know but lock
blocks here's what what sucked was lock
blocks did not go with Legos so like
when all your friends would get together
to build some cool like some giant
buildings maybe some Star Wars stuff I
don't know they're building big stuff
yeah I'm over here in the corner with
like 38 lock blocks building Jack I
can't even participate in the game right
they can't even participate with the
team yeah I'm sorry so I'm sorry so
there you go so yeah I played with I got
close I was I was I was Lego adjacent
there you go so you understand you know
what Legos kind of a sore spot over here
no real sorry because you're like real
did you have real legs Legos were a
massive part of my whole life I still
currently have all my kids do now but I
participate 100 oh yeah I got my kids
lit for real Legos legit Legos oh yeah
well there's different sizes too there's
like you know I'm on the lock box
no I can't wait to Google lock box and
see if they're still around yeah
um Legos uh tool toolbox
um anything where you have essentially
okay so Legos I like I liked the analogy
because
um Legos are like if you know how to use
Legos you know how they work you know
how they interact with each other and
how they they might not interact with
certain parts and how they do in their
exercise certain parts and you have a
direction and a goal or whatever and if
you the more Legos you have and the more
different types of pieces of Legos that
you have the more you cool stuff you can
build so you can be like I want to build
a rocket ship cool do I have the Lego
pieces or at the very least enough Lego
pieces to make a rocket ship how big a
small whatever like you can kind of do
anything with the right Lego pieces but
if you don't know how they work if you
know how to put put them together if you
don't have like any direction or
whatever they're just a bunch of Lego
pieces no matter how cool or capable
those Lego pieces are so in leadership
it's essentially you can have a great
team of people this guy's so good at
this this guy's so good at the other
thing like a football team I've always
thought was a really good
um representation of a team with
leadership and you know because everyone
has their different roles right you can
have the best quarter the best uh
wide receiver is best writing about all
this stuff if they don't work together
if three guys are pissed Four Guys hate
this guy this guy's jealous of that guy
like they just won't they won't work
together the same way you can't put
together any kind of Lego construction
if you don't know how the pieces work
together if you don't know where they
fit together yeah you know I really like
that analogy it's a it's a really close
my only problem with that analogy is the
Legos I understand no no no no no no no
no what kind of person looks at
Legos and says I can't understand how
these things work
[Music]
I wish there was something there was
some component of that thing that there
was some sort of understanding of what
you had
because anyone can look at a Lego and
say oh they fit together like this yeah
now I understand you get these high-end
sets which I I kind of I'm I'm more like
a traditional Lego dude right I think
you should get like the regular ones
maybe some long skinny ones maybe some
long the little flat ones maybe some
angular 45 degree angles and then you
you can work with that right you don't
need to be getting all with the things
that get real specific like custom
almost like a custom Lego right but your
analogy is correct and Leadership is the
person that's going to take these pieces
and get them to all build something
great yes you are correct yeah so if you
um
where you go okay the idea of it's like
you know it would be a little bit better
of an analogy is chemistry
sure you know a chemist can look at
these different elements and say oh I
need to add this element this element
this element like in the book Blood
Meridian they're out of gunpowder
and
the judge
knows how to make gunpowder and so they
are able to create gunpowder yeah no one
else could take the various components
and create gunpowder he could so that's
a little bit better of an example than
just Legos sure as Legos yeah you don't
like Legos no no no it's not that I
don't like it Legos but anyone can
figure out you're like you can figure
out how to put Legos together I mean
dude you gotta be a real well real
ignorant person we'll figure out how
them things work I I feel that as well
but I just have a lot of experience with
Legos but okay again and then again look
but
think about it try to call me on my Lego
skills yes sir but and look I'm not Lego
competitions we have competitions for
everything right do they have Lego
competitions that they must I wonder
what the challenge is it'd be cool if it
was an engineering challenge where it
was like oh you gotta build a you know a
three foot span of bridge and it's got
to carry this much weight there's your
Lego challenge because anytime you make
something
oh which is kind of how good it looks
right kind of whack I would imagine with
something as versatile as Legos or lock
blocks as the case may be it would
depend on the kind of challenge like I
said like if it's an engineering
challenge that's a different kind of
challenge than just a quote-unquote
general Lego challenge like who what who
can make this spaceship because you know
how Legos come in sets right yeah yeah
so who can make that spaceship the
quickest yeah or whatever or who can
make the biggest yeah so I I don't know
and I'm gonna I think so the my answer
that comes to my head you sure this Lego
competition and I'm not going to see if
you're in in what do you call Bia wait
how about the Lego movies you must be
into those no have you not seen them I
I've seen some of my kids watch them and
stuff there's yeah I've watched a decent
amount of the Lego I think the first
Lego Movie with President Business which
I think is one of the all-time classic
games and it's a interesting movie
because it's about creativity and having
an open mind which is very important
thing to teach young kids and in
interestingly what I don't like about
that is there's some people
have various levels of that
open-mindedness people have various
levels of creativity and to sort of hold
that
as a standard for a kid and be like hey
it's sort of like if they made a movie
about being tall
you know there's some kids that are not
tall right right and where do you draw
that line so it's really cool to say
like hey I have an open mind and be
creative and create new things
a lot of people don't have that Knack
right yeah they and that's okay you know
it's the last podcast that we did talked
about that and it talked about it in a
real politically incorrect way oh for
real a real politically incorrect way
which is like oh if you score this score
on the standard test that we're giving
to all people in the army
Actually I don't even know if we covered
this on the podcast because I might have
just skipped or I might have uh not
covered it but they had like a
standardized test that you took in 1941.
wait you're are you still talking about
The Lego Movie or no well I'm about to
okay which was oh you take the standard
test and you have a certain level
capacity to
learn to do math and they go okay if you
got this on the test you can be an
engineer in the military if you don't
you can't be an engineer and by the way
if you're really low on this scoring
you're going to be on the bottom end of
the jobs that we have for you you might
be a person that's peeling potatoes I
mean we talked about this when we talked
about the the IQ test that they lowered
in the Vietnam War and they started
taking people that were mentally
disabled and allowing them to be in the
Army you know and that's horrible and
Jordan P I think Jordan Peterson I want
to say
something like 10 of the population has
a IQ of less than 85.
and then it's really hard to employ
somebody that has an IQ of less than 85
now they can be employed
but
you've got to find a job that is very
suitable for them so when you're making
The Lego Movie and you're exalting
creativity
what is the exalting mean like saying
yes holding up this is the best way you
want to be super creative okay there's
some people that don't because because
by the way you're not you can test
people for intellect but you can also
test them for hand-eye coordination you
can test them for you can test them for
creativity you can test them for problem
solving and and so we're exalting this
one type of thing yeah
and some people might think that's the
path they need to go down and yet they
don't have that capability you know a
good one is music right yeah some people
can hear
now you you can train and get better but
some people can naturally hear a C note
yeah they can naturally I think Jamie
Cochran can sing a c
right because she she went to college
and she was a singer and so she can sing
a c she could you can say you know Jamie
give me C flat until ah whatever right
hell yeah but there's and there's a
certain amount of natural capable
capability we talked about now this I
know we did talk about on the podcast
the tonal languages right so some people
cannot
here tone now listen I guess if you grow
up with a tonal language you would be
trained so maybe it's something that you
just didn't get and you can't figure it
out but the fact remains if they wanted
if I was a failure at picking up tone
and then they watched a movie and said
hey everyone should join the military
and the most elite thing you can do is
go learn Vietnamese and I'm like yeah
that's the best job you can get and so
now I go and I can't do it instead of
looking at me and saying hey you might
be good at this but you might be good at
that you might be strong you might be
fast you might be smart you might be
good at math but when we exalt one thing
and you know what I might be be tuned
being too harsh on The Lego Movie that
was sort of the impression that I
remember was I was like oh that's cool
they're trying to teach people just
don't follow what the package says yeah
just don't follow the directions every
single time and create what everyone
else created create something new you
know there's a whole thing about the
gluing of the pieces together that's
what's going on in the movie like like
there's people that just they want to
glue that thing together so it can never
change we made this thing we just want
this structure to stand and other people
are like hey man let's mix it up they're
exalting creativity again there's
nothing wrong with exalting creativity
but but if you're a person that lacks
creativity and now you're forcing
yourself to try and become a creative
person when what you should be you know
let's take engineer versus artist yeah
right there's some people that are going
to be a better artist there's some
people that are going to be a better
engineer if all we do is exalt artists
the people that should be going to
become an engineer might not get there
yeah or they might feel bad when they
get there right and I think that's the
key there where and I don't remember the
message of The Lego Movie I just
remember it was on kids are watching it
I liked the effects watch it next time
watch it for real it's a good movie yeah
yeah I understand even just what you
said I was like huh that makes sense but
he and keep in mind I don't know maybe
I'm just sort of maybe being a devil's
advocate in this way where
um if there depends how they're exalting
the creativity so if they kind of start
with
hey the the mainstream is people
following the directions gluing the
pieces together and like these other
people who specific or some version of
this where the other people they're like
hey I don't want to necessarily do that
I've because I'm field toward I'm pulled
towards this other thing to start
experimenting the first off that's how
Legos really are in real life yeah you
put together the thing and then after
that you break it apart and then you
just start making whatever in fact
you're not going to follow the
directions more than once we're about to
go down we're about to go down it's
about to go down here's the thing I
think lately we've been exalting
creativity so much that people are are
just trying to be different for the sake
of being different and what the reason I
can bring this up right now is because
as we read through the iching you're
gonna say you're gonna see that a lot of
what they're saying is like be normal
yeah be normal is a positive thing now
it kind of bummed me out because when I
was going to college there was a woman
there that was a Buddhist monk and when
I when I was in college I had to take
classes about religion and you get that
vibe from Buddhism which is like hey
don't stand out you know fit in like you
just want and that's why when you go to
you know when I was in Thailand and we'd
see the Buddhist monks guess what all
the Buddhist monks dressed the same they
all have shaved head they all wear the
same outfit they all eat the same they
walk they like that's part of the gig
that's part of the thing is hey I'm not
trying to stand out I'm not trying to be
a big individual but there was this
woman that was a monk at my college
and if she was obeying Buddhism guess
what she would have done in my opinion
in my judgmental opinion which I
certainly can be extremely judgmental I
would look at her she'd be walking
around she had a shaved head and she was
walking around in in the Buddhist outfit
right
and I was thinking and she was a western
woman you know she was from Canada or
something like this and I was thinking
oh if she was really on board then
wouldn't you just want to like quote
unquote fit in with everybody else well
maybe look I'm not a Buddhist I don't
know but I definitely got that that
thought in my mind now there might be
some part of Buddhism that I don't know
which is hey you need to represent so
other people can see it I don't know
maybe right there's some religions that
you gotta dress a certain way yeah
because you wanted other people to see
that you are representing the the
religion or a cult because you know what
bhagwan SRI rajnishes do you know what
that is oddly yeah I kind of do yeah
okay well they made a they made a
documentary about it wild wild country
did you see it no well I was very
interested in because when I was growing
up
one of my friends
parents were into that they were like
and they would wear these orange or
whatever purple outfits and that was
part of the
is it okay to call that a cult right now
I think it might be
yeah okay so they were that was part of
the cult was like you gotta dress that
way so other people can see that you
represent the cult yeah I don't think
Buddhism is like that I don't know
either like I know there's all these
like surface level things that you're
like wait a second and they they you
know there's a lot of questions for sure
um now with that of course with
superficial observations all your
questions it's like man if you don't
look into it hurry up and get the
answers to the questions I get it so I
get it's like a little thought exercise
which is very useful but I know you're
just joking but obviously there's no
merit to cast any judgment if you don't
know all this stuff right it's like
judgment not ignorance whatever so the
Buddhism could be I don't know if it is
like hey because my Buddhist people out
there I'm sorry it's like uh you know
you're letting go of like certain like
real world materials like stuff right
and one is hair like and just like oh
you said hair is just here to look good
we don't need it we're here for you said
they win but Buddhism might be like hey
we're here for different reasons you
know so here we're not gonna let that be
part of our real our Earthly The
Possession or Pride or ego or whatever
right there's that there's like all this
other stuff just like fashion and just
like there's probably a bunch of stuff
that Buddhism lets go of So You Gotta
Wear that certain thing as a
representation of that that's currently
the what we arrived at that's our best
representation of it uh it could be I
don't know but it could be hey if by the
way when you say our best representative
you mean that's what you and I cut a
couple idiots on a podcast talking to
each other all right that's how we are
interpreted at this time actually I'm
even just saying mine really yeah
Mayhem that could yeah it could be way
off probably am but either way it it
stands to reason to some degree or
whatever hey that might be it right that
might be how or maybe they're like hey
if you can find a better representation
of this idea that goes super deep or
whatever if you can find a better
reposition then hey we'll do that but
right now this is currently what we're
at and this is what we're doing for
these very specific reasons and boom
along to bring this back a little bit
what I'm saying is if you are exalting
being different
and that becomes the main focus of
everybody
then people that want to kind of conform
are now feeling like in order to be
successful in life their main goal
should be to be different than everybody
else and it becomes a focus of life to
be different when maybe you should focus
on getting better maybe you should focus
on creating maybe you should focus on
participating maybe you should focus on
being a productive member of society
because if you could be like like if you
for instance someone that has a less
creative mind
and they could be a really incredible
construction worker they could be really
incredible in a factory they could be
really incredible uh doing and being an
engineer being a doctor right does a
doctor require creativity no they're a
they're a mechanic for your body so
there's all these jobs that don't
require this
for you to be different and quote think
different
and yet we're exalting those things to
the point where someone instead of
saying oh yeah you know what this looks
like a good job this looks like
something I could be good at I actually
enjoyed doing that kind of thing I'll
just go do that yeah instead we're
saying no you got to do something
special you got to do something
different and I'm just saying in my
opinion that's a problem instead of and
and where where you get a to your point
if you've got someone that has different
thoughts and wants to be different and
is naturally different when we're trying
to force them into Conformity each one
of those two ways is equally wrong
trying to take someone that is just
should be normal and trying to get force
them to be different is just as bad as
taking someone that's different and
trying to force them to be normal yes
and I think right now we're on the
pendulum side of everyone let's you know
you're different be different don't
conform yeah there's a
and again we're going to get into this
this and that's why I'm like cleared hot
talking this topic
there's a lot of it you know like I hey
I
like you're talking about what you wear
sure or what I wear what a human being
wears for me I don't want to wear
something that that people would notice
you know what I mean like I I don't like
to I don't if someone gave me a you know
a purple and pink uh tie to wear yeah I
I don't want to wear that I don't want
anyone to say oh that's a weird tire
that's a nice tire that I don't want
them to even notice that I'm wearing a
tie like what's the normal colored eye
to wear it's a you know it's a black and
red tie with will start something that's
the normal that's the normal thing yeah
I want to be normal yeah right I'm not
wearing uh the flashy sunglasses I wear
the normal sunglasses yeah that's kind
of like and and when I see somebody
that's wearing stuff that is
specifically made for attention I'm
always like okay you know it's a little
bit of a little bit of a thing yeah
right so I could even say that if you're
a Buddhist monk and you're in a
university setting where everyone is
wearing you know the professors are
wearing whatever uh a pair of slacks or
whatever you know like a there's a let's
face it there's a uniform for a college
professor sure it's pretty wide range
but there is a uniform right you're
wearing pants or if you're a female
maybe you're not wearing pants but
you're wearing a whatever a skirt type
thing or a dress you know I mean there's
there's a there's a a window
that you're gonna fit in
and wearing a Buddhist monk outfit isn't
in that window so if you're wearing it
you're definitely going to draw
attention
and if you're drawing attention well
that might not be representative of
trying to conform and fit in so there
you go yeah I mean and then again we
don't know what Buddhism is it sounds
like a defending Buddhism what I'm
saying is we can't just assume we know
like what if the intention to fit in or
stand out isn't part is it's the
intention not the the result you know
we'll we'll get someone on here we'll
get a Buddhist on here to talk to talk
us through this because I don't want to
sit here and just discuss no we're
discussing things that we don't know
anything about yeah we'll we'll be quiet
we're sorry um but real quick with the
Lego Movie and and I say this because
this is kind of a very this is an
important distinction where if they're
exalting creativity like as if to say
like hey being creative is better than
than being less creative or whatever or
following the instructions or whatever
if they're saying that then okay that's
that's bad but if the message overall is
and again I forget the actual message
but if the message is hey we're all used
to this and there's a number of people
who aren't very happy with this and
they're they're really pulled to do this
other sort of creative as I said the
messages is fine yeah the message is
fine to say hey if you're feeling
creative or you feel like a creative
person you want to do things that are
different that's cool yeah but to tell
everyone in that group yes that putting
the glue on the Legos and building
things that are going to be stable and
structured is bad that's not right yeah
I agree that's not right so let's not
get crazy with it let's not take
anything to an extreme let's be balanced
yep so there's also a movie and you will
not want to necessarily talk about this
one so bear with me there's a movie
called tall girl because you mentioned
height you can't control height right so
there's a movie called tall girl and
it's a you know the classic story a girl
in you know Junior High and she's taught
way taller than everyone like way taller
and it's one of those things where it's
like they made the movie obviously one
of the reasons was because hey like
there are some people who they're not
quote unquote average height and they
feel left out they feel weird you know
and the movie basically sheds light on
the idea that hey if you're a tall girl
you can still live life or whatever
don't feel weird is what I'm saying like
hey let's not uh and that's why I asked
like what does exalt mean because does
that mean like
hey let's try a light on and then show
that it's not terrible it's not you're
not a monster if you're tall you're not
or it doesn't mean like hey if you're
tall you're actually better yeah average
people you know that would be the
obviously no one would say hey that's a
great movie telling people that are
taller that they're better right exactly
right so that's the point we don't want
to do that right so even so I don't know
if the Lego Movie said that correct what
for one thing being tall yeah right so I
don't know if the Lego movie is saying
being the person who makes different
stuff
it definitely Paints the creative person
as the more heroic person oh okay so
that's why I'm calling it out
we can't go we don't want to do that and
the weird thing is like let's say you're
a parent what do you want your parent to
be what do you want your kid to be you
want your kid to be all creative and
special and all that stuff
instead of being like Oh I want my kid
to to do what is natural for them some
people naturally will be better as an
engineer than an artist
and don't try and force people to do
something that they're not and and don't
say well can't just be more creative
child why are you trying to follow the
rules all the time right you know like
that kind of thing yeah you know you
know what I think the grand scheme of
things I I do think I do not know what
you think of it
with what you just said I
I think that parents want their kids to
be safe more than they want them to be
like CR of course creativity that's a
good thing to be helped and Foster and
all that stuff or whatever but you know
that I'd say this this story this quote
unquote like hypothetical story is more
common this is what it feels like anyway
for you
the story is usually the parents want
the kid to do something that keeps them
safe and more secure for success and
like that kind of stuff more so than
hell yeah take some chances if you're
pulled towards that they're gonna
they're gonna be mad like so many
stories is like
um yeah they
I went to college for my parents and now
you know I don't want to do it all right
quit college because that wasn't my
thing that wasn't my I don't want to go
off the tracks I want to do you know
like stuff that I want to do I want to
take risks I want to do the creative
stuff Meanwhile my parents just wanted
me to be a doctor or a lawyer an
engineer or whatever yeah so it's I feel
like the parents that's usually the case
they want them to be safe I would say
that you have one you know you're
looking at one perspective because
there's definitely parents out there
that you know are pushing their kids to
be different yeah there's no especially
right now right now there's definitely
parents that are pushing their kids to
be their primary goal is to make them
different
and that's not good
you gotta your kids let your kids be who
your kids are yeah yeah that different
sake of being different yeah you know
it's funny when you meet guys like in in
the military you'll meet people that
they're like they'll have usually have
some weird name
especially you can't speak on it yeah so
when I was especially when I got in to
the military so like we're talking 90s
you'd meet some guy his name would be
like whatever freaking Haiku sure anyway
oh your parents had peace yep yeah like
you'd know that their parents are
hippies like I'm one of those yeah
you're one of those people so
yeah your name is haiku uh yeah there's
people so my point is that their parents
wanted the kid to be different free
spirited but the kid's like dude I'm
joining the freaking Army you know what
I'm saying get me away from these
freaking weirdos
that's a good point yeah so all right
next one the need for Unity and
Collective awareness of the goal dude so
that one right there this is just good
leadership advice make sure everyone
understands and is Unified towards a
collective goal everyone needs to know
what we're doing and and be on board and
the next one says do not procrastinate
so if you shook that magic eight ball
every day and it said do not
procrastinate that'd be good advice
and then join with others and return to
the plan okay that means focus on the
mission
next restraint brings progress and
satisfaction
I've heard people say that discipline
equals freedom restraint brings progress
and satisfaction yes discipline equals
freedom
make minor changes and conceal all
actions
[Music]
can't make minor conceal all actions
maybe that's a little bit sketch
the why and by the way I'm not reading
all these although I read a lot of them
the wise leader benefits from Harmony
Good Fortune approaches this is fortune
cookie stuff right there right like oh
I'm not really sure what's going to
happen with this next project we're
doing oh
we should work together Harmony yeah
it's a good good advice good good job
yeah the fortune cookie thing I think
jams you up because we as individuals
think the fortune cookie is made
specifically for us that's what all of
these things are well that's what so
okay here's something I used to do
so I'd I'd be like out of talking to a
girl yeah and she'd be like what sign
are you yeah and I'd be like Sagittarius
but you're not a Sagittarius but they
would say like oh I knew it oh because
you're realized and then then they'd and
then I'd say no I'd let him talk for
five minutes about how much of a
Sagittarius I was and then I'm just
kidding I'm outside the church are you
serious what are you and I'd be like a
scorpion and oh my God I knew it it's
what a scorpion a Scorpio would do but
I'm not a Scorpio you see what I'm
saying
and I would trap him with that too so so
all these things are made for everybody
it's kind of like who's gonna win the
war right or no what will happen if I
invade this country oh a great nation
will fall okay great I'm gonna do it
yeah you end up falling and you think
what was wrong with the Oracle the
Oracle is Right War causes the fall of a
Nation just don't know which one so I
guess in a way it's kind of like
in a way it's kind of like Marketing in
a way where
it's this is the general term that's
widely beneficial right this these
philosophy these elements of philosophy
right where it's like hey don't make
excuses right but me as the individual
I'm coming to you with a specific
problem don't tell me some widespread
philosophy I need the one for my problem
right I open the fortune cookie I come
to ancient uh Jocko the ancient Master
you shake the eight ball yeah I shake
the eight pole you ever seen the
Jamaican one where they have the bones
they might throw some bones too same
deal they can tell you that same thing
where this is ancient wisdom that
applies to everybody but hey I come to
you with my problems so like hey give me
the answer to my specific problem and
then yours like make no excuse you just
grab from the group bucket gave it to
the individual and it landed weird right
it's gonna land that's the thing that
you don't know it's gonna land oh yeah
if you if you come to me with your
problem and I say be disciplined that's
gonna land you're gonna be like yeah
it's going to solve your financial
problems gonna solve your health
problems it's going to solve your
relationship everything I solve that
problems but because you came even when
you read about how to throw the coins or
Draw the the sticks for this
it says you know think deeply and it
also says you might get an answer that's
wrong because you weren't really
thinking but you were thinking about
something else
all right next one strong persons give
way to the inferior
good advice right I give that people
people that leadership advice all the
time it's called listening listen to
other people listen to your subordinates
the enlightened person remains reserved
to avoid Misfortune yes don't make
yourself stand out
don't wear your freaking pink and orange
jacket
next one
reorganize the dependence of all upon
their fellows
say that again reorganize the dependence
of all upon their fellows what does that
mean everyone's got to work together
cover Move
the wise person seeks Collective flow to
gain Advantage yes we cover and move for
each other work together
resist evil exalt good
proper leadership brings great progress
this is but hey if you gotta shake your
eight ball every day you know you gotta
you're you got a drug problem you're
addicted to alcohol you have
opportunities to do things that are
nefarious and it says resist evil exalt
good guess what good advice these are
all this is all good advice
this is all good advice
uh
progress comes by equality of extremes
what does that mean it means be balanced
so next so from Harmony with supporters
does the wise person gain Advantage yeah
yeah harmony with the people with your
supporters for sure that's going to help
you
next one's about flexibility the
enlightened person adapts
leads from leads the way from Darkness
to comfort so that you got to adapt
in fact the whole this is Lake above
Thunder below this is flexibility
be flexible that's what they're saying
cultivate action in others to bring
about repair and great progress
get people to go
it's like good advice so the enact so
the enlightened person
willing to teach and learn from others
progress comes through persistence
they're big on persistence but yes
willing to teach willing to learn yes
that's positive thing that's that makes
sense the rulers of old traveled the
world they visited its regions and
contemplated its many cultures explore
new ideas
that's always going to help you
next achieve progress through reform
administer Justice those are positive
next the wise person perceives and
avoids disputes
it's really good advice to give people
oh there's a dispute that's going to
happen I'm going to avoid that again we
could go down that doesn't mean we're
fearing any you know confrontation and
we're never gonna do it but we're
probably gonna we're we should find a
better way yeah
we should find a better way that's what
we should be doing that's what I
recommend doing
enlightened people stabilize their lives
through generosity toward the needy
beautiful
help other people especially people that
need it
the enlightened person studies that pass
wisdom to develop his own character yes
I think we made an entire podcast about
that about studying the past wisdom to
develop our own character yes
that's a hundred percent what we should
be doing support goals that are above
question
but be cautious in expression and avoid
the negative correct persistence brings
one good Force
and that's you know as as I'm reading
these
when it talks about persistence in some
of these
predictions it's telling you be
persistent like there's some people that
don't have that
the ones that say correct person so then
you'd be encouraged but there's very few
of them that say Do not pers do not
persist there's very few of these that
say that most of them are encouraging to
keep going
the enlightened person withdraws from
progress withdraws from the world to
progress toward an independent goal
stress is imminent
what do I like about that if you've got
goals you got things you want to get
done there's going to be stress stress
is a minute be ready for it
that's a good thing
when you when when someone tells you you
know when you go set out to do something
I'm like hey man there's gonna be it's
going to be hard yeah that steal if I
tell you psychologically this impact on
you if I say oh yeah here's an example
hey you know if you came up to me and
said hey Jocko if you rolled with Fred
yet that new black belt from this
Academy yeah and he wrestled in college
have you rolled with him yet I go yeah
man he's he's not he's not as good as
you think and he's not very strong
you'd be like okay cool and then you
wrestle with them or you train with him
and he's like actually strong actually
regardless of how strong he is
he's gonna feel stronger because your
your mindset was he was weak right right
if I told you hey this guy's a killer
he's freaking strong as hell he's gonna
feel weaker than you anticipated in most
cases yeah in most cases yeah that that
idea of getting caught off guard with
certain things that you never really
thought about you know the small
detailed things like uh like um fasting
was one that you know when you fast it's
like oh you're gonna feel hungry or
you're gonna feel like the certain
feelings that come along with fasting if
you're not ready for him you'll be like
uh and you won't be able to deal with it
but yeah being able to kind of brace for
impact in a way you know you got to set
the right expectations yeah right it's
just like when someone tells you like a
movie is awesome yeah that's the worst
thing you can tell somebody about a
movie I actually know I was going to see
little birds with Elgin James sure hell
he was going to I was going to the
preview so it wasn't out yet and we're
driving to it
and I say hey man I was like so what's
the what's the story with this
and he goes oh you know he says there's
two girls and they're living out in
Island California and out by the Salton
Sea and they want to get out of that
town
and he's like it was like me and you
grown up but I was like oh that's
awesome man I go so then what happens he
goes well then they go to he goes then
they go to La and
and goes sideways and and you know
dude I'm I'm not even thinking about
this like oh what goes sideways I'm like
what happens this is as we're driving to
see this okay like a seven minute drive
I go so what I was like oh what goes
sideways and he goes
um
I'll just let you see and I was and we
said that I was kind of like
uh dude like are you serious right now
you know what I mean I was kind of like
bro like just tell me this is no big
deal like I don't care about your silly
movie or whatever you know what I mean
kind of like that like of course you
know like I just but I was just like
okay my mind was okay but I said like
okay you know I was trying to be cool
about it yeah and then
when the movie was over I was like thank
you so much for not telling me how that
went down because it is like very
impactful yeah and if you know it's
coming
it's not going to hit you the same way
yeah boy it hits you boy movies Little
Birds by Elgin James uh I think you can
get it on you know the streaming
platforms I think you can get it on
Apple yeah
um what is Apple TV yeah I think it's
not a brand new movie though no no no
that's right sold have you seen little
birds no oh I saw the trailer yeah it is
one of those movies where
you you definitely you're not going to
feel comfortable or good
about things when you're done yeah no
you'll feel okay at the end of it you'll
be like all right we're gonna be okay
but in the middle in the towards the end
of it you don't feel good about the
world you know you're kind of not
feeling good about the world and I guess
that's sort of the
the little uplift at the end there's a
little bit of an uplift at the end you
walk out of the theater but you
definitely yeah so little birds
you know how and just like what you
essentially were saying you want to go
in fresh to these movies yes and Elgin
James you know good Autumn where he he
wanted you to go in French but the weird
thing is like this is my bro yeah like
where you know he would literally tell
me anything I would literally tell him
anything that's why when he's like I'll
just let you see the movie I was kind of
bro wait what were you thinking I was
thinking he was gonna tell me like oh
yeah this is what happened oh you were
mad he didn't tell you I was kind of
like yeah it was almost look this is a
guy that I grew up you know like we've
been together right and I we tell each
other whatever like every every little
detail so it was probably the first time
in my life
that that I he was like not gonna tell
me something yeah and you're offended
not a fan and I was slightly offended by
no no never mind you kind of no I was
like slightly offended like bro are you
serious right now yeah like you know
we know everything yeah we would tell I
would I would literally tell him
everything yeah for my whole life and
now all of a sudden he's like well I'll
you can wait and find out I mean it's
just jacked up he's jacked up at the
time it's messed up but so but what he
what he was doing was actually you were
offended by that you weren't offended by
like what you say about this movie is
not gonna affect me either way so you
should just say it wasn't that it was
just the fact like Oh I thought you were
my bro you're not gonna tell me bro you
told me literally everything that's
happened in your whole life yeah yeah
and I've told you everything that I have
in my whole life everything and now you
made a silly movie yeah you're not gonna
tell me what the plot is and I'm gonna
watch it this is a seven minute ride by
the way it wasn't like we were in the
car for an hour like we're gonna start
watching the movie so I was like I was
frustrated that he was gonna tell me
like maybe we had a four hour car ride
you could see but I only had to wait six
more minutes to get to watch the actual
movie yeah but the it's very interesting
the way those expectations set your you
can set yourself up with expectations
whether you think this guy's going to
roll good or this guy's going to roll
bad or you know you can really put
yourself in a good spot or a bad spot
based on what what your expectations are
and you have to be very careful with
your team when you do that when you tell
someone on your team oh we're going to
dominate this presentation
oh I've worked with this client before
they don't ask any hard questions okay
cool now people don't prepare and the
first question is going to be a doozy
right so you got to pay attention to
that
um
the wise person learns confidence
through Danger
remain calm in mind keep all actions
virtuous again
read that to yourself every morning
right and confidence through danger I
think we could probably ah my
interpretation of the Chinese word is
discomfort right or or putting yourself
in situations that you're not used to
that's how you gain confidence right you
gotta you gotta be outside your stress
level now this doesn't mean you go out
you know if you want to get more
confidence in fighting you don't go and
challenge the freaking you know two-time
state champion wrestler from California
that's a black belt in Jiu Jitsu and you
don't talk smack to them no no you start
by training with someone that's a little
bit better than you and you start to
gain confidence eventually you can train
with people that haven't been training
as long as you and you get more
confident so yes you have to you have to
push yourself beyond what you're capable
of in order to gain competency and
confidence
keep all actions virtuous hey amazing
ancient wisdom or common sense I don't
care do it
next the enlightened person cultivates
intelligence and gains progress through
correct persistence
align yourself with goals that bring
enlightenment
yeah don't do dumb I think we just
did a podcast about that
marriage brings Good Fortune
I had to put some question marks by that
one because that is not a known true
statement again this is when you when
you read these now and you think of them
as predictions as you are going to roll
or flip the coins and you're like should
I marry you know Jessica
and then it says marriage brings Good
Fortune you're like okay I'm in
but here's the thing if you're asking
that question in the first place is that
good or bad
um accept others and act openly I think
that's a great advice
all change is imminent yep things are
going to change activity and change
teach well the value of endurance stand
firm and move with persistence toward a
goal
this thing leans toward being persistent
persistent that's what it leans toward
and that's a good way to lean in life
a good way to lean in life is keep going
now listen let's say you were the guy
that was made that made this thing up in
order to make some money by doing
predictions for people you could
probably say be persistent eight times
out of ten and then two times out of ten
you're like maybe push to pump the
brakes a little bit yeah and what
happens let's say you say oh I want to
try a new business venture I'm like yup
be persistent and it's not doing very
well and you're like should I keep going
and I say yup be persistent and you say
wait a second It's really hurting me
should I keep going and by now you get
one that says hey pump the brakes you
know what I'm saying so it's best to be
persistent for a while and then if you
keep having to ask that question maybe
it's time to pump the brakes so that's
why they put correct persistence yeah
that's another reason you know the that
whole thing and you know we you always
talk about this uh idea of um
giving up versus pivoting versus you
know like the idea of like hey it's
tactical Retreat yes tactic so it's more
like if you understand uh your end goal
you're not giving up on the brick wall
you're just hey let's not beat our head
against it let's go around it or let's
do this you know oh so there's there's
always that puzzle to sort of to solve
so like correct persistence is one of
them where
it kind of seems actually straight up
does seem like
persistence not like beating your head
against the brick wall yeah right so
it's like okay like yeah I gotta get
past this walk to my other goal to then
get my uh my uh overall goal right you
got a brick wall then you gotta maybe a
hill right then you got the other goal
I can't get through this brick wall
correct or persistence is like keep
beating your head keep trying to
whatever correct persistence is hey hit
it once hit it twice as you say not 27
let's let's maybe take a quote-unquote
longer way and it'll be quick so around
the brick wall now we got a hill we're
still going up the mountain Yeah Yeah so
basically correct persistence is hey
don't give up on the overall goal yes
don't stop with it don't say hey it's
too hard for me or whatever be like hey
correct persistence is let's not get
hung up on these little challenges in
the same way we got to be creative with
these and change our like methods or
whatever as long as we get to that
overall goal so persistence doesn't mean
beat your head against this brick wall
it doesn't mean correct person walking
10 steps up the hill and falling back
down a hundred times correct for since
this is don't give up on the end goal
you can change all these little tactical
things in between that's exactly what I
wrote about in the book leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual yeah
so
um
this is a good one very similar same
vein the Tranquil Mountain occasionally
hexagram 33 Heaven above Mountain below
Retreat the Tranquil Mountain remains
quiet under Heaven's gaze so does the
enlightened person maintain dignity in
retreat
like hey sometimes you gotta back out
that's cool so again you you came to me
with your little business that you're
trying and I kept killing you persist
and then finally I'm like retreat is
okay seven out of ten times you're good
occasionally you got to retreat eight
out of ten times maybe you're good
occasion got a retreat
the wise person acts within convention
and with persistence
use influence wisely hey this is what
I'm getting back to like act Within
there's a lot of that undertone
in the iching of like conform
act within convention this is the advice
that it gives a lot and guess what
if I'm trying to give you advice that
percentage-wise is going to work out the
best
most the time I'm going to say hey take
the conventional route right you know
what I'm saying if you're like hey you
know Jocko I don't know if I want to be
uh an engineer or a movie star yeah I'm
like hey
work within the convention yeah you know
and that's probably going to be the best
advice to give there's a small chance
you're going to miss out on being a
movie star which I'm sure you're
probably pretty pretty good one but most
of the time seven out of ten eight out
of ten nine out of 10 times telling
someone to do what's being done is a
good move let's not try and reinvent the
wheel next
so does the enlightened person reveal
virtue conditions favorable for Progress
again that's like telling you about your
specific question that you're going
through
um conceal goals but do not abandon them
trying conditions but correct for
correct persistence brings one to
Advantage yeah hey man keep going maybe
conceal your goals a little bit but keep
going
the enlightened person acts in an
orderly and substantial way
faith and loyalty must be nurtured
good advice the enlightened person only
acts in small matters
maintain individuality
the enlightened person examines and
perfects his own behavior to gain
strength
this is incredible advice have you shook
the magic eight ball or opened your your
fortune cookie
and it said perfect your own behavior to
gain strength that's good advice you
should do that
the enlight the enlightened person finds
good fortune in quick action to restore
normal conditions
forgive others faults what incredible
strong advice forgive people when they
mess something up forgive them for the
faults that they may or may not have
and take action take action to get
things fixed
and again you see that little idea of
returning to normal normal is a thing I
like normal
I like normal I think normal is good
yeah no there's a reason why things are
normal because it works
I'm not addicted to normal I don't I
don't maintain normal for all situations
but normal is a really good Baseline for
life
yeah and even the word normal does is
very uh multi-dimensional if you will
where change in and of itself is normal
like it's pretty abnormal for something
to be the same no matter what it is
but yeah that abnormal stuff
correct me if I'm wrong but isn't normal
sort of in in right today 2023 sometimes
taken as offensive sometimes yeah if if
I say oh this is normal and then all of
a sudden if you're not that you have a
problem right yeah
um wait it's offensive if you're not
normal or normal is bad so if I was like
like that movie you're talking about
tall what's it called tall girl
hey you're not normal right because
you're tall yeah right that can be
offensive yeah but you can apply that to
like any thing that is actually not
normal what is normal is it a percentage
for normal hey 80 of people hey 80 of
people are between 80 of girls
at age 12 are between the heights of
whatever four two and four eight or
whatever I don't know what it is but
whatever it is is it taller than that I
don't know but whatever it is that's
actually there's a you could prove that
that's what normal is right but now if I
say that's normal just say oh well
that's not you're like like let's say
you took your kid to the the doctor and
they did the weight or sorry the height
measurement
and
they said oh your kid's not normal
yeah you'd be a little bit mad me pretty
no no I feel like then again this could
be just me but I think it's General
where normal is still one of those real
in the middle of the road words that's
like depend really depends on how you're
saying it like if your kid's acting a
certain way and you say hey act normal
then normal's gonna be good I guess I've
seen enough like triggered videos of
like
that's not how do you know what normal
is like that kind of thing right right
no no no no I'm saying that you know
when we talk about the percentage of
people that have this characteristic
it's 87 of people are this way yeah and
that means that is actually normal yeah
so if don't be you can't get mad at that
yeah I think I think people get mad at
that yeah I mean you don't want to get
mad at that that they're not considered
normal when it's just a I'm sure there's
some kind of a mathematical right yeah
you know calculation to figure out what
normal is it's normal it could look it's
normal 70 I bet we all I bet if you ask
people what percentage is what
percentage constitutes normality yeah
you probably get oh it's probably
between 68 like if you asked a thousand
people what percentage makes something
normal I think people would say 70 or 75
yeah yeah and I'm gonna then I could be
wrong about this but normal feels like
more of a feeling so it's like what
you're used to right in my environment
just because no you know the norm but
I'm saying that feeling that you're
talking about if you tried to isolate it
or at least get a bracket around it I
bet that most people should have measure
it yeah if you try to measure it most
people's feeling about what normal is
would probably be around 75 yeah uh and
the the reason that I say and I would
agree with you and but but the reason
I'm saying it's a feeling is because
technically
if you have
100 people and let's say let's go 50
actually let's go 40 40 have this one
quality very specific quality out of
about you know 30 qualities
30 of them even I'll even go down 30
have this one quality the rest of them
have a bunch of different other
qualities it's almost like the majority
versus the you know the non-majority or
minority I still don't think that's
normal right okay so you you wouldn't
call that normal okay okay cool cool but
where's the line drawn you know so you
just said it so but here 70 okay let's
go seventy percent
let's go it let's say there's
five percent variation
across the board all 100 people they're
all different by a factor of five
percent like at five percent of this
five percent of this this other thing
whether it be tall short whatever
the idea that there's 20 variants are
all equal yeah there's 20 variants and
they're all equal they're all yeah
they're different right but there's 20
variants let's say you could have 20
different eye colors yeah yeah and
there's and they're all five percent
yeah more or less yeah there's no
majority or minority they're just
dispersed evenly right where are we
going it's pretty evenly in this town
okay right for everyone to make a new
podcast called hypothetical Echo okay
the the idea or the fact that the idea
that everyone has all kinds of different
eye colors right is normal for that town
yes but if you go to the town one more
town right next to it where everyone has
the same color eye color having
different eye color in that town is not
normal okay so I'm saying so normality
goes it's like it's I don't know it's
like a real flowy real fluid kind of
feeling depending on your environments
what it feels like yeah
look what's the norm the norm in that
first town was you have different
colored eyes the norm in the second town
is you have the same colored eyes yeah
that's the norm or the very that's very
specific color eyes yeah that's what I'm
saying when you make a group of people
and they all have something that and 70
of them have some specific thing yeah
that thing is normal yeah normal so okay
so what do you say are you thinking or
saying or whatever that you feel like
nowadays normal is kind of looked at as
bad or yes if you're if you're not
normal
then that means you're different and
different is bad is that in that way
yeah it always say and obviously we're
different so we go through different
things but it lands on me that it really
like 100 depends on what the context is
so if it's like oh my gosh you uh like
someone okay so like I saw in the news
this girl
um I don't know they said her name I
forget but anyway she's a freshman in
high school she's on the track on the
varsity track team Varsity softball team
gets a 4.6 GPA right this little girl
and she's I think she's like one of the
top sprinters on the team or whatever
none of that is normal nope but
it's abnormal we'll call it in a good
way so if someone's like wait a second
they read this girl's paper so so your
point is which I think this is your
point normal
people think that means good and not
normal means bad when I don't think that
I think
I think that there is a such a thing as
normal though right there is such a
thing most girls freshman year are not
making the varsity track team and
they're not making the varsity uh
whatever so so that's what normal is so
if your daughter when she gets to high
school and she doesn't make Varsity
track you can be like that's okay that's
normal yeah and she shouldn't be like
so I'm just normal or if she does make
it and you're like whoa you made it
that's not normal wait I'm not normal
you see I'm saying people people hype
this word a little too much and I think
there's a benefit to knowing and
understanding what normal is yeah and
there's a benefit to sometimes saying
hey I don't want to be normal and
there's a benefit to sometimes saying I
want to be normal
and that's where I want to get to yeah
that makes sense
right on I it's like a political party
there could be a political party there
should be a political party that's
called normal
like I'm just a normal person you got
these extreme views over here you other
people got some extreme views over there
I'm not extreme on it in this
what's my political party normal yeah so
I'm just a normal person and actually
because I'm an American I'm a normal
American yeah we could probably get with
80 accuracy what a normal American
thinks politically and then there'd be
20 of Fringe elements yelling and
screaming and going crazy
and the way we have it right now there's
no normal
there's only one there's only either
Democrat or Republican
and there's a there's an overlap for
sure that they that they could find a
common ground on but because of the
areas that don't overlap they just hate
each other yeah it's essentially this
the I'm gonna make a political party
called normal like but see people would
be so pissed at that well because anyone
that then that is not normal would be
mad at you for saying that you're normal
and they're not yeah do you ever think
and this is what I think and I could be
wrong because I know about maybe
10 people
[Music]
to that degree so
I think on the internet
um
anything that makes the news yeah I
think in everyday life I think of course
there's two parties of course there's
some overlap but I think even within the
two parties
they have different philosophies
different approaches to how the country
should be or run or you know all this
stuff but there I think they're pretty
normal even by by normal most people are
normal I think I think so when I travel
around this country and I and I travel
around this country and I meet people
from all over this country from the blue
States from the red States from the from
the you know most liberal areas to the
most conservative areas I meet them all
most of those people from those extreme
places are normal same exact same here
man like and I don't go to all but
there's no political party for them to
join yeah they can't vote normal like if
normal doesn't get a vote yeah isn't
that like the nature of a party nowadays
anyway nowadays in general where it's
like hey if you're now you just join the
because everyone's so different in all
kinds of different ways there's gonna be
you know five or six issues that are
like what do you feel about this I feel
it's this and then there's levels within
the issues and it's all gonna fall
within like
a realm of like oh I see why you're you
think that I see what I think I think
but if you don't know the person
and you and you're only listening to the
extreme people on the internet who's
yelling the loudest all this stuff or
whatever yeah it'll seem like that but I
think in real life just like how you
said in real life you you might have a
politically charged person but they'll
probably even be normal yeah they're
more normal than they think I mean they
might be not normal on one little uh
political issue but most of them they're
pretty normal yeah so but they have no
one to vote for
right you can't vote for someone there's
no normal person to vote for if I was in
a political party I'd be in the normal
one I'd be like yup I'm normal I'm just
average like I'm an average person hey
should we have no taxes no you've got to
pay taxes to pay for infrastructure so
we have extremely high taxes no I just
want normal taxes yeah normal taxes you
know that's how you hey should we dump
all of our money into defense no but we
need to have a good defense okay cool
how much do we put in defense normal
amount
do you know what I'm saying like these
people are crazy they're not normal
not normal there's no there's no one for
a normal American to vote for yeah
and guess what
when someone is acting normal they get
called abnormal by the extremes on both
sides it's crazy that's what normally
happens
all right next
the enlightened person acts with
moderation boom
that's what they're telling you to act
normal act with moderation avoid anger
develop confidence sacrifice brings Good
Fortune freedom from error again
beautiful advice for any human in any
situation act with moderation avoid
anger develop confidence and if you
sacrifice you're going to get Fortune
there you go great advice next an
enlightened person sees the good action
of his fellows imitate them and correct
their mistakes to make progress toward a
goal okay you see someone doing good you
should do that thing too
you know correcting their mistakes if
you're doing that for yourself so if I'm
watching Echo and I see how his life is
going
and I can imitate those good things and
I can correct whatever mistakes you're
making I can learn from it that's all
they're saying
great advice imitate people that are
doing good and if they're doing
something that's messed up correct it
when you do it yourself
next do not use Force but rely on Fair
judges
know your goal tell your supporters the
idea of look if I have to impose and
force you to do this
there's something wrong there's
something wrong
if I have to force you to do this there
is something wrong
so don't let that happen did you see
that PBS uh clip they had Dr fauci going
through
Baltimore I think it was Baltimore
anyways and they're trying to convince
people did you see this viral video clip
and this guy's like hey if this vaccine
was good you wouldn't be trying to force
me to do this right now you wouldn't be
trying to pay me to do this thing I
would just want to do it the guy's like
there's something suspect about that and
fauci's trying to con you know trying to
he tries for a little bit to convince
him and then he just moves on and he
just gets met with full resistance uh
and he can't here's the interesting
thing
you know I've been talking a lot about
this ex explanation effort meter which
is how if it's really hard for me to
explain something to you there's they
might not be such a great idea so listen
if I'm trying to get you to do something
and I can't and you're presenting
arguments to me arguments to me and I
can't overcome them
maybe my idea is wrong yeah
maybe my idea is wrong
so rethink it
and you can you can see when this
happens
and you see it on that video because you
got fauci's trying to convince us trying
to explain to him and the person's like
well doesn't this not actually prevent
you from getting the disease and he's
like well it kind of does well kinda you
know stickers are one of these things so
be be careful for yourself when it's
really hard for you to explain something
some ideas some plan if I'm like okay
Echo here's what we're gonna do
and you asked me a question and I have a
hard time answering or I can't answer it
and you ask me another question I can't
answer and you ask me another question
I'm like hey Echo I want to sell these
widgets you know and I'm like well and
you say well how much do they cost to
make and I'm like well it's not
important about the cost and you're like
well it kind of is because if you want
to make a good you know price point on
them and then we can't sell them to
anybody and no one will buy them and we
make something we can't sell don't you
think that's wrong and I'm like no no
but they're really cool yeah
like be careful when your explanation
effort meter is in the red shouldn't be
that hard to explain uh this is what
happens with public transportation
like in California the public
transformation sucks it's not good they
can try and get you to use it
but it's not good so as much as they try
and convince you it does not effective
because it's not good whereas in London
it's easier to get into town if you take
the tube in New York City it's easier to
get around because because the Subway
because there's no traffic on the subway
so if something is good you just
voluntarily do it
that's the way things are supposed to be
that's where new methodology should
happen oh this this way that I'm trying
to get you to do something is better let
me show it to you now listen if I'm
trying to get you to use a new process
in our company there might be a time
where you're less efficient at this new
process like hey you've been using some
video editor
and I say hey Echo there's a new video
editor out and it's way better and you
look at the uh the
components of it and you say oh yeah
that is better so now you adopt it for a
little while you're going to be worse
yeah because you haven't developed the
skills yet over time you know you're
going to get better that can happen in
any organization you start doing
something new people efficiency is going
to go down
but if efficiency doesn't get back up
there's something wrong with me if I
can't show you this new video editor
where you're like oh yeah that's a
really easier way to do that and oh yeah
that's much more effective and then you
go give it to me I want to do it but if
I'm like hey no this here all you have
to do is Click these 47 buttons and you
can copy the video thing you're like
well I can do with one click on the
other thing yeah but you know the see
I'm trying to explain something it's
real hard yeah
so just be careful pay attention to your
explanation effort meter
a ruler issues commands that become well
known do not create a relationship with
powerful persons or ideas
exert discipline
it's always good to exert discipline I
was kind of wondering about the do not
create a relationship with powerful
persons or ideas and I think what I took
away from that is don't be married to
your ideas
right don't just be like no this is my
idea
don't fall in love with your own plan
and be careful about when your boss has
a plan you know you don't want to be a
yes man good advice Unite with others
make sacrifices and act with correct
persistence to achieve a goal boom
act with sincerity avoid suspicion and
join with a wise leader
wisdom or common sense you be the judge
I think it's both
gradual change nourished by the
receptive Earth produces a path to
Virtue the enlightened person persists
in small matters to gain a fortune
yep Little Steps that's what we're doing
we're doing little steps the enlightened
person gains progress through courage
adversity needs risks to achieve Fortune
speaking alone is an ineffective is
uneffective but those are great the
enlightened person gains progress
through courage you got to take some
risks
Fortune good advice
truth is never exhausted yet never the
same
the enlightened person gains insight
into truth and assists others to achieve
it
if the truth is not heated bad fortune
follows
what I like about that is I like the
idea of assisting other people to
achieve truth as opposed to ramming
truth down their throat or punching them
in the face with the with the truth
because that doesn't doesn't help
doesn't work if that worked then you
could go on Twitter and you could change
people's minds by presenting the facts
the enlightened person
appreciates past experience and present
opportunity confidence and progress is
confidence and confidence and progress
only after change is passed
appreciate past experience and present
opportunity yep I'm happy where I've
been hey be thankful that you went
through some struggle and look for
opportunities right now
the wise person aligns himself with
established order it's going back to it
hey be normal
just be normal it's a good place to
start
it's a good place to start the
enlightened person seeks to improve
himself improve himself and take
advantage of the unpredictable great
advice oh there's a lot of Mayhem going
on cool take advantage of it the
enlightened person turns his back upon
the larger situation and loses
self-awareness
if you this is the opposite of some of
these things that say talk about the
small goal this is saying if you turn
your back on the larger situation you're
going to lose self-awareness you're
gonna be it's not gonna go good you have
to pay attention to the larger situation
the Strategic vision
the enlightened person improves life
through Good Conduct and correct
persistence boom
so it's yes we want you to follow these
things intelligence combined with
activity
this is the Zenith of achievement the
enlightened person trusts his own
judgment and makes progress
do not fear decline but Shine Like the
Sun there's going to be setbacks
everybody it's okay Shine Like the Sun
the wise person is clear-minded and not
detained by disputes Isn't it nice to
just move on
some little issue some little spat maybe
it's even a big issue maybe it's a big
disagreement cool move on
the enlightened person acts gradually
towards small goals
consistent theme in here
the wise person exchanges ideas with
others to find cooperation open your
mind
open your mind
solid
rulers meet with their subordinates
great leadership advice
advantage and cooperation correct
persistence and the company of fellows
yep join a team and hang out with your
team meet with your subordinates
the wise person develops sound
restraints and decides proper conduct
extreme limitation though is no virtue
so this is getting discipline equals
freedom and dichotomy into one little
sentence right develop sound restraints
and you'll figure out what what
direction to go into
you'll you'll you'll know the proper
conduct when you have the right
restraints when you have discipline
it's going to point you in the right
direction
but Extreme limitation if you go
overboard with something it's not going
to be good it's no virtue
from a distance the wise person gains
understanding oh detach everybody from a
distance the wise person gains
understanding yes please detach take a
step back
get some altitude get some perspective
moderate disputes
and
must avoid rigidity
don't be stuck in your ways
open your mind free your mind as the
mountain as occasionally I'm reading the
Thunder above Mountain below attention
to detail as the mountain remains
tranquil in activity so the wise person
conducts himself with dignity and
control don't be an emotional idiot
be remorseful in losses and Frugal and
expenses when birds fly too high none
hear their song
stay grounded you know what I'm saying
is that what they mean by the expression
down to earth you know down down to
earth persons down to earth yeah you
know I never I never knew what that
meant down to earth I thought I thought
it meant like um
he's real uh like a you know like in
touch with reality kind of yeah I think
well that is that is a pretty good it's
like humble right it's definitely not
they're not trying to yeah it's
definitely humble but you could be let's
say I was like Hey Echo uh you you want
to go to Vegas with me and you're like
yeah and I was like okay I'm flying up
there on my jet tomorrow so just meet me
up there when you can with your jet
you know what I mean it would be like I
was not down to earth
but it well then again I don't know
maybe right now I don't know really what
it means or maybe it's both I don't know
I I thought Down to Earth was like
someone who's really easy to understand
and relate with
but then what I thought I understood
later currently is that down Earth means
like
humble in touch with like basically a
king in his Tower is
um gonna be talking about King stuff
meanwhile everyone else is talking about
common or stuff right so you're so both
things that you said are correct yeah
down to earth means like oh easy to
understand humble not talking about like
well you know the thing is when you get
a private jet you gotta really focus you
know what I mean like that's just
that's not very down to earth no you
know
um so down to earth yes it's humble it's
also like relatable right it's
yeah it's both it's like humble in a
very specific relatable way easy to get
along with kind of a deal totally yeah
that's down to earth it's a very
positive thing all right we got two more
of these hexagrams to cover
the enlightened person defends against
forthcoming adversity great great idea
Mike Glover approves
progress only in small matters confusion
is imminent okay so there's gonna be
some confusion out there
and last one the wise person attends his
position and pro and progress carefully
progress with great vigilance yep pay
attention
there you go uh you can see that
a lot of these things are common sense
but here's the thing if these things are
such common sense why are we not doing
these things right and it's interesting
that psychologically even if we flip a
coin and it tells us to do the right
thing that kind of pushes Us in the
right direction to take action right to
to trust like all these things like that
little flip the coin or in this case the
drawing of the yarrow sticks or the the
drawing of these uh
this divination form
will push you in the right direction my
advice would be
you know don't wait for the flip of the
coin just do the right things and and
you actually know what they are it's
common sense but it's Common Sense
versus ego it's Common Sense versus
laziness it's Common Sense versus habit
don't wait for the flip of a coin these
are things that you actually know
so just do them
I know why we don't do laziness ego
habit what well yeah these are all like
within the you know in the spirit of
Jaco simplifying things or whatever
we're distracted from it that's why so
and there's a bunch of things that can
distract you for sure but the main ones
are entertainment or your mood right
like how you feel so ego I guess it's
not mood but like how you feel so
working out for example
everyone
if you're on the Internet or let's say
if you're in America pretty much
everyone knows that working out is
better for you than not working out
everyone knows that factory then why
does actually everyone work out like
everyone
yeah lazy I'd say I'm sure laziness is
in there for sure for sure but the think
about it you're actually going to be a
better human being you're gonna live
longer you're going to be healthier yeah
everything in your world is going to be
better and you don't do it there's a
lack of discipline laziness that's a
horrible thing yeah so and hey
occasionally there's someone out there
that like doesn't have time they got
three kids they're a single mom they're
working two and a half jobs like I get
it they're not working out I get it oh I
I get all reasons why people I get why
that's the case but here's the thing I'm
just saying what keeps someone from
making the decision to not work out
versus to work out because we all know
now
a workout can be 10 minutes versus zero
minutes it can even be five minutes
versus zero minutes like we know like
you do burpees as many as you can for
five minutes yep that's that's a workout
of work out and it's gonna be depend so
we all know this right so but what is it
that makes us make the decision the
actual conscious decision down on the
street level to be like I'm not gonna do
that right now or to not even think
about it you seem to know what's your
answer being distracted you're
distracted by something whether it be
you're feeling your mood your uh
something else you're not paying
attention that's where I kind of don't
agree with you at least on some level
there's times where you look distraction
with me and oh man I forgot to work out
like I was watching Instagram oh I was a
fell into like nine YouTube movies and
now I didn't work out that can happen
yeah allegedly right it can happen you
can let the window close but let's face
it when you're letting the window close
and if you're not don't remember what
I'm talking about we used to talk about
the Jiu Jitsu window is closing like hey
you know classes at 4 30 and you're
trying to wrap something up and if you
don't get it done by four you know by 3
35 you're gonna be late and then you
just kind of let that window close and
you're not training yeah so when you get
the window closed for sure yeah but I
don't think that's just distraction
would mean I forgot about it I don't
think that happens
um and you are correct but I'm talking
about on a deeper level
so I'm saying for real on a conscious
decision-making level down on the
streets uh-huh
your mood will distract you from the
idea that knowing the right thing to do
is to work out but what would make you
think hey right now what's driving my
decision is causing me to do the wrong
thing literally the wrong thing and it's
your mood so to accommodate this mood is
distracting me from a better decision
yeah it's like it's like if you want to
use that form of distraction yeah then
that then I understand what you're
saying okay you're allowed to use it you
can use it because let's face it
there's no there's maybe you once in a
while you you get
distracted where you go oh dang it's
already freaking 6 45 in the morning and
I had to jump on for an email and then I
started watching a YouTube video and
then I went down the rabbit hole and I
got literally distracted where I didn't
but I I actually can tell you this I
have never in my life gotten distracted
and missed a workout yeah so I might
have chosen and said like bro that's you
know it's leg day and I'm gonna watch
more YouTube videos right now I'm going
to put this thing off yeah I did but it
didn't happen in a subcon distraction to
me is a subconscious thing where it's
like oh I got distracted yeah oh I was
driving and texting that's distracted I
hit a freaking tree yeah I get it and
that's that's true I didn't I didn't
wasn't texting and now I missed a
workout
that didn't happen right all right I get
it and I am not saying that you're wrong
but in the spirit of understanding not
I'm writing you're not right or I'm more
right than yours that's not the spirit
the spirit is in the spirit of
understanding so distraction
[Music]
we'll go with it all right what made
sense is when you said you can allow
yourself to be you can choose to be
distracted instead of choosing to do
what you should be doing but I think on
some kind of other mental level it's
more of the idea and think of it as a
concept right the idea of keeping your
eyes on the prize right you know that
idea yeah so keeping the eyes on the
prize right okay so the prize is
the benefits of working out right right
and even if you're not a fitness person
and in fact you've never worked out in
your life you're going to know at least
one benefit of working out right yeah
you're gonna know it's better to do it
than to not do it people are going to
know that stuff so let's say that's the
prize the benefits right if you keep
your if you take your eyes off that
prize and look at another prize your
eyes kind of got distracted from the
price I'm saying so on that level is
what I mean like by distracted or
whatever that's why I said in that form
you can use it and I understand what
you're saying and you're you're correct
yeah kind of like real minor kind of way
you're right so hey I'll take it I'll
take it thank you uh so
let's not get distracted let's try not
bro it's hard it's hard because even in
the real uh I should say direct away
it's easy to get distracted
and it's on purpose too that's what
that's that's what I think you you
choose to get distracted like you can
easily choose to sit down and watch some
YouTube videos or flip through your
Instagram right
and then and then you add on top of that
fact that the dopamine is getting in you
and it's just dopamine dopamine and then
now you're just like more dopamine more
dopamine don't mean you do this right or
I don't know maybe you don't I'm pretty
sure you said you did this so you know
like if for example you're gonna do some
hard workout thing
and you're like oh you don't want to I
don't know some 20 rep squad or I don't
know some hard workout thing and you're
like looking around stretch another
round they'll do a warm up on the bike
let me uh oh wait wait let me check that
email on my phone real quick you know
I'm hoping that there's a freaking
tragedy at one of my companies that I
gotta go deal with so I don't have to do
your 20 rights my workout bro I'll find
little things that like need to be done
you know like I'll be like oh man I'm
you know there's like this weird routine
before a workout if I'm really not
feeling like it like so I'll drink a
water right so while I'm drinking water
I'm like oh wait oh shoot that little
corner needs to be cleaned real quick
you know so and it kind of like it's
like a form of distress like purposeful
distraction and procrastination mix
together totally well the E Chang says
don't procrastinate so let's take care
give you advice all right well we want
to stay on the path we don't want to get
distracted let's make sure we're fueling
the path correctly get yourself some
Jocko fuel jocklefuel.com
yourself some of these energy drinks
which are for a godsend yep I hear
there's like uh looks like the Nobel
Prize is going to be awarded tons of
Taco fuel for making these they weren't
100 sure until they made their ready to
drink milk and now it's just they they
realize that the recognition is deserved
so get yourself some Jocko fuel energy
drinks that have no downside
no downside
it's not like well I need energy right
now I'm gonna I'm gonna sacrifice future
energy for current energy that's what
the other guys do they sacrifice future
energy for current energy we will give
you current energy and you'll still have
the future energy no crash
nootropics
95 milligrams of caffeine sweetened with
monk fruit tastes freaking delicious
there you go get some of that get
yourself some Mulk get on the Mulk train
oh yeah that RTD one just keeps paying
dividends see insane and you know you
want to talk about getting distracted
when it comes to like
for me the the effort meter for food
prep I have a low I have a high bar for
what I'm going to put into it right like
you you want to talk to Leif Babin and
you like hey you want to eat dinner he's
like yeah man it was like hell you know
fire up the grill at two o'clock I'll
start marinating food tonight he's gonna
be on that grill for two hours like he's
putting effort into it I'm not doing
that it's not me it's not my thing it's
not right John Dudley yeah dude this
this dude will have a plan like three
four five days in advance we you know
he's turning on the Traeger at you know
at at nine o'clock in the morning he's
turning on the Traeger he's putting the
meat it takes six hours to cook you know
what I'm saying there's none of this I'm
not doing any of this I'm opening up tin
chicken and putting mayonnaise in it it
took me 30 seconds to to make my meal so
I have a very high bar as far as the
effort that I'm gonna put into to prep
food
the RTD milk is a complete Game Changer
it's a it's the healthiest thing you can
just rock and roll right now yeah and
just get stronger
while having dessert yeah it's true uh
jockofuel.com also go to Wawa go to
Vitamin Shop go to the military
conversation it's Hannaford Dash doors
in Maryland wake fern
ShopRite
HEB and Tejas Meyer those are the big
retailers hey thanks for going into HEB
thanks for going into Meyer we're we're
dominating in there dominating the
Vitamin Shop as well
so I don't think the results are out yet
but we're either the number one brand or
the number two brand in vitamin shop
which is awesome
some people voted for that was a voting
situation brand V brand yeah so that's
why and I saw that too and so I went on
there and did you vote yeah
I have a very strong opinion and
actually when I looked at it I was like
oh yeah I'm voting and maybe I
overthought this whole thing or maybe I
did maybe I put the perfect amount of
thought into it so I'm looking right at
it it's like um the it was ready to
drink right RTD was like and the go was
in that so I'm like cool and I'm you
know I'm checking my bias you know
because I'm a responsible human being in
my mind so I I scroll and I see who who
else is here though you know like what
else I'm looking at this other one I was
like bro I would never vote for any of
these things I'd only vote for this one
the healthy one the good one
award-winning yeah so like all right so
yeah I think it's Justified is what I'm
saying so it's not one of those things
where it's kind of like hey like it
sucks but hey I like you Jocko but it's
like it's lit it's factually better than
all this other stuff so good good on you
jocklefuel.com go get it
um originusa.com also you're gonna need
some Jiu Jitsu in your life right
because Jiu Jitsu is one of the magic
eight ball solutions to problems is
train Jiu Jitsu we encourage it we also
make jeans we make hunt gear
and we make it all In America which is a
big deal it's a big deal because there
is
ecological disasters going on in the
world
and there's slavery modern day slavery
that's happening right now in a
sweatshop
in China
and you can go support that you can go
support enslaving another human being
or you can go to originusa.com and you
can get some American made
the highest of quality
gear
for your entire life t-shirts
sweatshirts boots hoodies
Jiu-Jitsu geese look can you wear your
ghee to work you can right to me it's
sort of like wearing a you know being a
Buddhist monk at a university and
dressing like that I don't I don't think
you should I'm not gonna hold it against
you this was probably the one kind of
outside the box uniform except if I saw
you wearing I'd be like you know what
we'll go with it right you want to wear
that ghee probably wear a black ghee be
less obvious than a white ghee yeah you
know as far as going to work in
depending on where you work yeah I guess
if you worked in a hospital you could
wear the white key and that might look
pretty dope but you worked in a in some
kind of a financial industry I'd
probably wear just a black key you know
just a little bit more subdued you know
what I mean yeah so dude you're going
into a meeting you know you don't want
to be standing out with a bright white
ghee no I don't remember that black key
yeah yeah so when you wear a rash guard
underneath you know yeah that's why
we're normal if you wear your ghee to
work tag me in a picture I want to see
it I'm gonna see what you know I just
want to see kind of maybe in a little
video Jiu Jitsu instructor as a job does
not count Jujitsu instructors a job does
not count yeah you gotta have a some
kind of normal job yeah
let's face it Jiu Jitsu instructors at a
normal job nope no there's no there's no
box right like when you go to a survey
it doesn't say Jiu Jitsu instructor
there's no box that says you know it
says are you in service industry are you
in the financial industry there's no box
on there that says are you in the Jiu
Jitsu instructor industry it's not
normal it's not a normal job yeah they
would have to kind of in a way kind of
shoehorn it into another industry like
um Fitness sport yeah even Fitness that
doesn't attack like sports maybe but not
everyone competes so it's like
you're just a jiu jitsu instructor it's
not normal we support you though we
support get yourself some get yourself
An Origin USA ghee
yeah by the way or do you say.com also
Jack has a store it's called the aqua
store this is where hey man on this path
it's hard
it's hard but there's other people
there's other people on the path with
you
anyway you if you want to represent
that's where you can get your shirts and
uh and hats and hoodies and some a lot
of good stuff on there so yeah that's
what we've been hearing yes
that's the reports uh from the from the
field because it were subscribed to the
podcast subscribe to Jocko underground
go subscribe to the YouTube channels get
psychological warfare go to
flipsidecanvas.com get some cool stuff
to hang on your wall from Dakota Meyer
get one of the books that I've written
or published go to extreme ownership.com
and learn how to lead
this is not something you learn in a day
it's something you got to follow up with
that's why we made that online Training
Academy go check that out and that is of
course through Echelon front which is
our leadership consultancy
just got back from Gettysburg the
Hallowed Ground to Gettysburg the thing
was sold out that's the thing you got to
watch out for
the stuff that we do is sold out and so
if you want to come to one of our Live
Events you have to register early in
order to go so go to go to
echelonfront.com check out our Live
Events or check out if you need
leadership consultant consultant
Consulting in your team
you got to go there as well and we'll
take care of you and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families check out Mark
Lee's mom mama Lee she's got a charity
organization that is
doing an incredible job helping our
Warriors and their families if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to America's Mighty Warriors dot org
and also don't forget about Micah Fink
who apparently right now is skinning a
mountain lion
with his bare hands that he killed with
a with a tree branch
while he is of course back
and if you and he's doing he's showing
he's showing veterans and First
Responders I think he's got First
Responders in there now too he's shown
them how to find themselves by losing
themselves out in the wilderness
horses and heroes sorry Heroes and
horses dot org go check that out if you
want to connect with us Echo Charles at
Echo Charles Docker will link at Jocko
willink but be careful because it's a
distraction platform it's meant to stay
take your eyes off the prize don't let
that algorithm grab a hold of you and
thanks to our military men and women in
uniform that are out there
around the world sacrificing their
freedom to protect ours thank you for
what you do and the same goes to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
and all First Responders you all also
make sacrifices every day to keep us and
our family safe and we thank you for
what you do
and everyone else out there
speaking of what you do
you know what to do
you know what the ancient wisdom says
you know what the common sense thing is
and you don't need a coin toss or a palm
reading or a tarot card to tell you what
to do you already know
and that is to get up and go get after
it
and until next time zeko and Jocko
out